[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
manuel valls bonjour manuel valls
beaucoup d'être avec nos anciens premier
ministres on est ensemble pendant plus
de 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentait par julien
lécuyer de la voix du nord bonjour
julien dont je revienne bonjour ne sait
pas même jour et on commence évidemment
par cette crise sanitaire et cette
flambée épidémique avec des chiffres qui
deviennent alarmant et l'alertent
général sonné aujourd'hui au plus haut
sommet de l'état conseil de défense de
nombreuses rencontres pour jean castex
vous qui avez été à matignon vous qui
fait aussi beaucoup d'allers-retours
entre l'espagne et la france deux pays
très touché par cette épidémie de
coville est ce que vous pensez que la
stratégie du gouvernement est la bonne
moi je pars du principe notamment face à
cette crise que toute polémique toute
critique n'a pas n'a pas beaucoup de
sens donc il faut agir il faut agir pour
sauver des vies pour pour prévenir la
ligne de crête est particulièrement
étroites puisqu'on voit bien qu'il
s'agit de freiner de faire reculer le
virus et de l'autre côté sauver sauver
l'emploi parce que nous savons que les
conséquences économiques sociales de ces
crises vont être majeur en terme de
chômage de pauvreté et d'exclusion donc
cette ligne de crête est étroite
comment préserver les vies comment
lutter contre le virus est préservée en
même temps l'activité économique c'est à
dire éviter le confinement général mais
c'est vrai que depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est vrai en l'espagne c'est vrai en
france toutes les alertes sont sont
passés au à l'orangé ou au rouge ne les
propos par exemple de l'un de mes
anciens collaborateurs qui aujourd'hui
patron la rs d'île de france reliant
rousseau ils m'ont
m'ont frappé c'est à dire que à partir
du moment où les hôpitaux des services
de réanimation commence à être sous
tension
on assiste en plus à une propagation du
virus un peu partout et dans toutes les
régions
c'est la différence par rapport au
printemps ça n'est plus uniquement en
alsace où l'île de france c'est partout
y compris dans des départements euros il
faut il faut agir et donc j'attends avec
impatience et inquiétude aussi bien sur
les mesures qui seront annoncées sans
doute demain agir c'est pour vous 1 re
confinement inéluctable pour sauver noël
par exemple je ne sais pas parce que la
grande difficulté que nous avons c'est
l'absence d'horizon au plus tôt
l'horizon qui qui reculent
avant l'été on avait le sentiment qu'on
allait tous retrouvé la vie d'avant et
que l'économie en 2021 à les reprendre
et que nous allons que nous allions
compenser une partie des pertes de 2020
moi je pense est difficile de s'enfermer
dans un dans un cadre et c'est vrai que
les fêtes de noël en termes économiques
et puis surtout en terme de vies de vie
familiale enfants sont essentielles et
vous sont essentielles vous avez
parfaitement raison en effet le moral
est important ce qu'il faut c'est agir
maintenant pour freiner cette
propagation particulièrement inquiétante
en plus avec beaucoup d'exemples où on
voit que ce ne sont pas seulement les
personnes âgées ne sont pas seulement
les personnes qui ont d'autres symptômes
qui ont d'autres maladies qui sont
touchés mais quand cela touche des
personnes bien portantes jeunes les
dégâts sont considérables du point de
vue médical en termes de santé les
séquelles reste très important sur la
gestion de cette crise c'est vrai que en
espagne à une plus grande autonomie de
décision des régions est ce que ça
illustre une france trop centraliser la
gestion de sa crise pour vous je crois
pas parce que de ce que j'ai vu deux de
l'espagne au cours de ces derniers mois
la concurrence entre régions les
tensions entre les autonomies qui c'est
vrai ont toutes les compétences en
matière de santé et le pouvoir central
mais qui peut décréter ce qu'il vient de
faire l'état l'état d'urgence ce qui
amène ensuite
à confiner partiellement à mettre en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs à
fermer par exemple c'est le cas à
barcelone depuis plusieurs semaines tous
les restaurants et tous les et tous les
bars et tous les cafés ski pour la vie
méditerranéenne est évidemment un choc
considérable
je ne sais pas moi je crois quand même
qu'on a besoin d'une d'une vision
cohérente globale harmonieuse
rappelez vous de cette polémique a eu
avec avec marseille aussi mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut laisser agir les acteurs
de terrain en lien avec les médecins
avec des scientifiques et les maires les
élus et les préfets reste pour moi le
couple idéal pour mettre en oeuvre des
mesures manière la plus intelligente
possible mais avec les mouvements qui a
dans notre pays
ça n'est pas facile d'avoir une france à
plusieurs vitesses on craignait les
tensions on les sent monter en italie
elles montrent aussi à à barcelone et en
france on sens et c'est cette tension
monte entre les gens qui qui voient
leurs commerces fermés qui ont peur
finalement que de rester sur la paille
oui mais c'est il ya il y à des secteurs
le tourisme la la restauration
l'hôtellerie les loisirs et la culture
toute l'activité culturelle qui est
profondément touchée même si en france
il faut le rappeler
heureusement il ya un état les mesures
qui ont été prises depuis ce printemps
par le gouvernement pour aider
l'économie pour aider la culture il ya
encore des mesures qui ont été annoncées
par roselyne bachelot pour le spectacle
vivant le théâtre sont considérés tout
le secteur des transports tout le
secteur aérien et donc toute l'activité
économique autour sont profondément
touchés oui bien
bien sûr c'était quand la marée se
retire à pardon de cette expression on
va voir que non seulement il ya eu du
chômage de chômage partiel heureusement
mais qu'il ya du chômage il ya les
réalités
il ya beaucoup d'entreprises notamment
d'autonomes d'indépendants de
restaurateurs qui vont mettre la clé
sous la porte et dire que ne vont pas
reprendre leurs activités de l'activité
sera sera morte
et puis derrière il ya aussi c'était le
cas hier à barcelone c'était le cas il
ya quelques semaines est régulièrement à
berlin par exemple vous avez des gens
qui sur des thèses complotistes continue
à s'opposer ou à nier ce qui est en
train de se de se passer donc non moi je
veux saluer d'ailleurs l'immense
majorité des français qui ont avec
beaucoup de
beaucoup bien sûr d'inquiétude mais
aussi beaucoup de sérénité beaucoup de
discipline il faut que cette discipline
soit sans doute renforcer de nouveau
affronte affront de cette pandémie
on va parler de notre sujet c'est la
lutte contre l'islamisme et ce bras de
fer ces tensions entre la france et la
turquie
ces insultes même du président turc
envers le président français emmanuel
macron erdogan qui met en doute la santé
mentale des manuels mâcon vous publié ce
matin une tribune dans le figaro vous
dites r doan nouvelle référence des
frères musulmans se fait le chantre de
l'islamisme le plus radical et vous
plantez aussi dans sa tribune la
faiblesse de l'europe soumises au
chantage des réfugiés de la part de la
turquie
est-ce qu'on est condamné à
l'impuissance face à la turquie non mais
il faut être lucide
donc parler de la crise sanitaire de la
crise économique et sociale traversons
aussi la planète une crise
environnementale la question du
réchauffement climatique et la
transition écologique sont fondamentales
il y a maintenant cette crise qui n'est
pas nouvelle dans tout cas depuis 2012
2015 notamment la crise terroristes et
cette crise identitaire
je pense que rarement le monde l'europe
est notre pays ont eu à affronter autant
de crises en même temps le front le
front est large et le papy que je publie
dans figaro merci de citer vise surtout
à démontrer que ces crises terroristes
et crise identitaire
le combat face à l'islam politique n'est
pas mais pas que notre combat c'est une
question fondamentale présent la public
il y a quelques semaines aux mureaux
avait parlé de la nécessité que l'islam
change ce que le grand débat il est au
sein de l'islam c'est pour ça que nous
devons aider les musulmans qui veulent
tout simplement vivre leur foi à lutter
contre l'islamisme et c'est pas la
république qui luttent contre les
musulmans
c'est l'islamisme et l'islam politique
de l'islam radical qui veulent prendre
en otage nos compatriotes nos
concitoyens musulmans c'est pour ça
qu'il faut le protéger mais il faut être
lucide sur cette guerre que nous livre
l'islam politique les frères musulmans
notamment et dont l'une des références
pas la seule au sol financement par
exemple du qatar mais la référence
politique et qui cherchent à utiliser ce
moment pour des raisons internes aussi
de leadership dans l'islam sunnite ses
airs de galère ces insultes sont
insupportables bien évidemment il faut
où les condamnés mais derrière cela on
voit bien que c'est une tension
puissante avec la turquie en
méditerranée sur la libye où ils
protègent des milliers de terroristes
djihadistes qui sont partis de syrie de
l'état islamique vers la libye donc
toutes ses confrontations montrent les
dangers mais je pense que je salue le
fait que la france ait est
particulièrement ferme vis-à-vis de la
turquie mais il faut que leur offre sa
voix ferme elle a été souvent seul c'est
là était seul en syrie elle a été seul
elle assume pleinement ses
responsabilités déjà depuis plusieurs
années
et quel que soit d'ailleurs les
présidents de la république mais là ça
suffit d'une certaine manière il faut
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités et
on ne peut pas laisser la turquie dans
cette dérive et ce ne sont pas seulement
des mots
au delà de l'attitude atroces de la
turquie à l'égard des kurdes mais sa
confrontation y compris sur la question
du haut karabakh avec l'arménie en libye
je vais me le dire
les tensions en méditerranée seul avec
la grèce ou sur la question chypriote
montilla il ya un problème plus je
rappelle que la turquie est membre vous
parle de partenaires de l'alliance à
douar les deux guerres
est ce que à ce titre la turquie une
présidente sûrs que doit-il être
considéré comme un allié ou comme un
ennemi c'est une bonne question parce
que je je je viens de le souligner c'est
notre partenaire dans l'alliance
atlantique
c'est c'est une des armées les plus
puissantes de l'alliance atlantique
or et peut encore rester dans le temps
la turquie non je pense qu'à terme il ya
un vrai problème c'est le pas de punir
les turquie sont 1 un grand peuple et on
voit bien d'ailleurs que c'est le retour
des grands empires les perses avec
l'iran qui ont énormément profité de la
situation de ces dernières années qui
représente un vrai danger
pas seulement sur la question nucléaire
mais sur toutes les questions liées aux
armements balistiques et surtout cette
archive protectorat qu'ils ont imposée
aussi bien au liban en irak et et et en
syrie donc face à ces tensions il faut
moi je crois une stratégie diplomatique
nouvelle
il faut de nouvelles alliances
stratégiques il faut utiliser les
changements dans la région
nos grands partenaires doivent être
israël et les émirats et derrière cela
il faut sans doute oui
c'est l'islam politique cet islamisme
qui nous fait la guerre mais beaucoup de
fermeté des régimes de sanctions ne pas
dépendre des turcs sur la question des
réfugiés et montrer qu'en méditerranée
ils ne sont pas les maîtres
donc la stratégie pour vous ces deux une
montée en tension puisque le discours de
fermeté que vous appelez de vos voeux
il va finalement certainement augurait
aussi d'une montée en tension en turquie
jusqu'où on va dans les tensions mais
est ce qu'il faut c'est empêcher que ces
tensions ne monte de la part des turcs à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu des faiblesses
savez moi j'ai été très marqué par le
fait que les fameuses lignes rouges que
le président obama avait tracé
concernant la question syrienne sur
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques ont été
allègrement surprise à partir du moment
où contrairement à ce que souhaitait le
président hollande
les britanniques et surtout les
américains ne sont pas intervenus pour
frapper sanctionné au moment où c'était
nécessaire
le régime syrien cela a été interprété
comme un signe de faiblesse dont les
russes avec vladimir poutine
les turcs aussi avec erdogan déjà ont
profité bien sûr le régime de bashar moi
je suis pas belliqueux je pense que le
monde a besoin de paix mais il a besoin
aussi de fermeté sinon les populistes
cesser ces pays qui ont une certaine
vision en plus à long terme
interviennent donc c'est là on a besoin
d'une alliance puissante avec les
américains j'espère qu'il y aura une
nouvelle administration américaine qu'il
permettra à davantage de nouvelles
alliances stratégiques j'ai parlé
d'israël et des émirats en plus avec la
paix qui s'est noué sous nos yeux il y a
quelques semaines c'est pour ça que je
pense aussi que la france de reconnaître
jérusalem comme capitale d'israël
mais derrière cela y ait une vision
stratégique nouvelle parce qu'on peut
pas permettre 7,7 cette tension
je rajoute encore une fois que c'est une
manière de démontrer que il y à un grand
débat une grande confrontation au sein
de l'islam et que là il nous faut
vraiment expliquer ce n'est pas simple
bien sûr aux musulmans dans le monde
entier que ici en france les musulmans
sont protégés vivent dans la liberté de
culte et que nous sommes un exemple
celui des lumières qui touchent chacun
qu'on croie ou ne crois pas c'est ça la
laïcité ans à venir sur ces questions
mais un dernier mot sur l'air de gamme
puisque vous condamnez en vous
commencez à sucre comme à peu près
l'ensemble de la classe politique
française d'ailleurs qui soutient
emmanuel macron sauf jean luc mélenchon
qui refuse lui de soutenir emmanuel
macron face à ces attaques d'ardoyne est
ce qu est ce que vous pensez de
l'attitude de jean luc mélenchon sans
doute une dérive personnelle vision très
basse de la politique une absence de
courage parce que ça n'est pas une
manuelle mâcon qui est insulté seulement
c'est chacun d'entre nous sait c'est la
france et quand on est patriote et
républicains
face à ce face à ce personnage parle de
erdogan
il faut être unis j'ai toujours
considéré que sur les grandes questions
de politique étrangère face au
terrorisme dans cette confrontation il
faut être unis jean luc mélenchon et ils
sauront charmer public un nom mais jeudi
il est en tout cas il n'est pas la
hauteur une nouvelle fois plus mais
c'est normal parce qu'il est pris dans
des contradictions une heure richard
malka l'avocat de charlie hebdo la
résumer d'un mot peut pas être à la fois
charlie hebdo et au bon on peut pas être
charlie hebdo et mélenchon il est pris
dans des contradictions lui-même et du
coup elles s'étendent y compris sur ce
champ de la politique étrangère c'est
une erreur très très très lourde de de
sa part d'avoir écouté c'est c'est son
choix
non seulement il faut condamner les
insultes de erdogan
mais il faut soutenir l'action du
présent la république dans ce moment-là
compliqué dans ces tensions mondiales
notamment sur ces questions identitaires
c'est cette question de l'islam
politique
oui alors parlons de gérald darmanin
parce que le ministre de l'intérieur en
effet affiche une nouvelle fois sa
fermeté dans l'est dans libération
aujourd'hui notamment sur la fermeture
de la mosquée de pantin la dissolution
du ccf la lutte contre la haine en ligne
il fait ce qu'il faut selon vous il va
suffisamment loin je crois je pense
qu'on vous savez le l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit après l attaque qui a eu
devant les anciens locaux de charlie
hebdo et je pense aux deux journalistes
qui sont encore blessés
c'est un tournant enfin c'est une
bascule on ouvre sans comme ça même si
nous vivons avec des attentats déjà
depuis plusieurs années j'ai été en
première ligne face à des attentats
notamment 2015 et et 2016
mais ce qui a changé sans doute et c'est
ce que je vous disais sur le plan
international il ya un instant c'est que
l'ennemi est clairement désigné je
l'avais dis moi même il ya deux ans je
souhaitais qu'on dise clairement que les
frères musulmans et les salafistes
étaient les ennemis de la république et
cette fois ci on passe vraiment aux
actes de ce point de vue là
l'interdiction ne sera pas facile d'un
point de vue juridique mais il faut y
arriver du ccf quelle officine des
frères musulmans en france démontre que
c'est eux les adversaires c'est les
salafistes sont sont à un peul
l'avant-garde les vers laquelle
s'abritent les frères musulmans les
frères musulmans sont cette organisation
avec des liens partout une puissance
financière considérable solidaire un de
ses leaders qui erre de gan nous venons
d'en parler donc là on passe aux actes
d'où ces tensions d'où ces insultes de
erdogan
je rappelle qu'en plus ils l'utilisent à
travers des financements les
associations et le réseau consulaire
turc pour contrôler les turcs qui vivent
en france mais pour contrôler aussi
l'islam des turcs en france avait que
des conséquences sur l'ensemble de ce
culte dans notre pays c'est le cas aussi
en allemagne ce qui explique parfois la
frivolité la frilosité de l'ami alain
sur ces caractères dire les financements
de tout ce que les investissements turcs
puisqu'on voit qu'ils investissent dans
le doubs les écoles ils investissent
alors ils envoient des émissaires sous
forme d'un imam ou de ou d'enseignants
je pense qu'il faut toute la panoplie
doit être regardé il faut agir contre
l'islamisme et l'islam politique sur une
panoplie très large il faut éradiquer
cette islamiste dans le pays ça sera
long difficile on a parlé de guerre tout
cas ce conflit cette bataille cette
guerre cette confrontation comme à la
différentes dimensions internationales
et nationales
on est à la fois sur le champs l'espace
public des mosquées des des financements
c'est une bataille aussi culturelle
philosophique politique puisqu'il s'agit
tout simplement d'aider les musulmans de
france aussi a extirpé à rejeter cet
islam politique donc il faut agir sur le
temps c'est pas une seule mesure c'est
pas une loi qui résoudra à tous les jeux
d'habilité faire mais manuel valls a
sera compliqué sur le plan juridique
gérald darmanin le dit aussi ce matin
dans libération notre droit nous
mais pas de suivre efficacement l'islam
radical et l'islam politique est ce qu'à
un moment il faut dire eh bien il faut
qu'on change notre droit il faut qu'on
accepte de renier certaine liberté
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse
pourquoi il oppose le changement ou
l'évolution de notre droit avec l'état
de droit
je pense que dans le cadre de l'état de
droit de notre démocratie de nos
conventions internationales ou
européennes
on peut on peut agir la loi a beaucoup
changé depuis 2012 défendu ici au sénat
en 2012 je vais commencer par le sénat
quand j'étais ministre de l'intérieur
une première loi antiterroriste qui
tirait les leçons des attentats terrible
de montauban de montauban en p2 et
toulouse là où une école avait aussi été
attaquée parce qu'une école juive et des
enfants et un père assassiné il faut
toujours le rappeler l'école en france a
déjà été attaquée mais j'avais déjà
parlé d' ennemis extérieurs et
intérieurs alors que vous nous avez
seulement signalé une trentaine de
français où deux jeunes français partis
en syrie voyez l'évolution réelle des
lois en 2012
en 2014 la loi renseignements 2015 une
nouvelle loi pour permettre la sortie de
l'état d'urgence en 2010 est donc il
faut faire évoluer le droit avec la
sérénité qui s'imposent parlons à public
sénat on peut en parler d'autant plus
parce que nous savons que les sénateurs
travaillent bien sur ces questions là
une constitution on peut la réviser mais
ça nécessite l'unité et un accord bien
sûr entre l'assemblée et le sénat vous
le savez parfaitement peut sortir de
certains traités européens
les traités européens peuvent aussi se
renégocier on peut sur certains pointent
provisoirement on l'a déjà fait
notamment sur la question de l'état
d'urgence prendre la distance nécessaire
mais quel est notre devoir bien sûr
toujours garder l'état de droit la
démocratie puisque on nous attaque parce
que nous sommes une démocratie mais de
l'autre côté nous avons un devoir c'est
de protéger les français et de gagner
cette guerre qui sera longue difficile
je l'avais dit en 2015 devant des jeunes
ça va être long c'est une affaire d'une
génération
il faut se donner tous les moyens pour
être efficace notamment sur interdire un
certain nombre de groupes sur ses
problèmes juridiques est ce que vous en
tant que premier ministre à l'époque où
même en tant que maire d'evry parce que
les mères sont en première ligne sur ces
questions de lutte contre l'islamisme
radical
il ya des décisions vous auriez voulu
prendre et que vous n'avez pas pu
prendre parce que vous êtes dit ça va ça
va pas passer au niveau juridique
à l'époque nous étions confrontés
surtout au terrorisme extérieur même si
encore une fois j'avais signalé cet
ennemi intérieur et j'avais à la tribune
de l'assemblée comme du senate déjà
désigné l'ennemi c'est à dire
l'islamisme l'islam politique je crois
qu'il faut toujours se dire clairement
quels sont les adversaires ou très
lucidement décrire la situation mais
c'est vrai que trop souvent les maires
par rapport à une salle de prière par
rapport à une association par rapport au
financement de la politique de la ville
peuvent être démuni donc il faut que là
encore état et collectivités
territoriales travaillant le maire faut
les protéger bien sûr ce qu'il faut
protéger d'une manière générale c'est
tous les agents de nos services publics
à commencer par les enseignants et je
pense notamment à quelques jours de la
de la rentrée vous rendez compte vous
êtes enseignant aujourd'hui est à la
fois le problème sanitaire à traiter et
de l'autre côté moi j'ai eu des
témoignages bouleversants 1c il faut j
insiste sur le fait qu'il ya des profs
j'ai eu une lettre hier d'un enseignant
envoyait une amie députés mais non ce
jeune mais terrible sur le fait qu'ils
étaient confrontés dans une école aux
théories complotistes créationnistes
qu'il ya des cours qu'elle a du mal à
imposer
donc on voulait le mal est profond
regarder le rapport obin il dit
clairement ce qui s'est passé depuis des
années cette dérive y compris au sein de
l'institution c'est justement vous
appelez de vous appeler à renforcer les
la laïcité dans tous les ans dans tous
les rouages de la société lors il ya une
tribune qui est intéressant de françois
baroin signé dans le jdd une interview
pardon qui surgit qui suggère d'étendre
le périmètre de l'espace relevant du
service public alors par cette
expression on comprend qu'en fait il
veut étendre les espaces de vie en
commun où s'impose la neutralité par
exemple au complexe sportif aux
médiathèques ou transports où finalement
le voile par exemple serait serait
interdite vous même qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce pas est ce qu'il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin dans les périmètres
où le voile serait interdite c'est
le voile est devenu c'est ainsi l'un des
symboles de cette confrontation
je ne dis pas que toutes les femmes qui
portent le voile porte le symbole pour
des raisons de politique mais c'est
devenu ce symbole je pense que pour être
très concret pour répondre très
franchement à votre question vous me
connaissez je n'esquive pas cessé
question l'interdiction des signes
religieux pour les mères
accompagnatrices des sorties scolaires
j'ai eu ce débat y compris quand j'étais
premier ministre est pas pas réussi à
convaincre ni la ministre de l'éducation
ni le président la république ni
d'ailleurs sans doute le le parlement à
ce moment là mais je suis convaincu
débat on tourne autour depuis la
circulaire chatel
mais il faut là dessus être très clair
c'est une mission de service public de
même et jean michel blanquer elle a dit
très clairement aux saints l'université
pas dans toutes les universités
mais au sein de certaines universités on
voit même sur les questions
d'enseignement sur le port des signes
religieux sous la pression religieuse
qu'il y a au sein de ces établissements
là aussi je suis favorable à
l'interdiction des signes religieux bref
à l'application de la loi de 2004 dans
les universités c'est très important de
le faire et qu'on ne me dise pas que
c'est attentatoire aux musulmans parce
que là aussi une des leçons de ces
derniers jours c'est clairement de
démontrer que ceux qui nous ont accusés
pendant des années d'être islamophobe
parce que nous combattions l'islam
politique c'était encore un des mots de
jean luc mélenchon il y a quelques jours
ont fait beaucoup de mal ce qui nous a
accusés de faire la guerre aux musulmans
au contraire nous protégeons les
musulmans en faisant clairement la
guerre à l'islam politique et c'est ça
pose la question aussi vous parliez tout
à l'heure de la de cette gauche qui ne
peut pas être danièle obono qui donc la
députée la france insoumise et charlie
hebdo est ce que ça rend irrémédiable la
fragmentation de la gauche
vous savez si j'interviens souvent
depuis quelques semaines sur vos
plateaux ou si j'écris d'abord c'est
parce que j'aime mon pays c'est parce
que je suis un patriote c'est parce que
quand la france est attaquée comme
ancien premier ministre ancien ministre
de l'intérieur je me dois d'être d'être
aux côtés des des français mais c'est
aussi parce que je pense avoir eu raison
ça ne suis pas sûr d'où je me suis
trompé
bien évidemment sinon je ne serais pas
un ancien premier ministre
seulement mais sur la montée de
l'antisémitisme sur la question l'islam
politique sur les attaques contre la
laïcité
j'ai eu j'ai eu raison et j'ai horizons
aussi ce que j'ai appelé en 2016 les
gauches irréconciliables
il ne peut pas y avoir de trajet commun
il ne peut pas y avoir d'accord avec
cette gauche et islam au gauchisme cette
gauche qui s'est perdu avec les
identitaires avec des indigènes de la
pub peut pas y avoir de ceux qui se sont
éloignés des valeurs de la république et
de la laïcité dans la france insoumise
parfois au sein du parti communiste pas
tous bien évidemment parfois chez les
verts quelques socialistes
il ya eu aussi des attitudes e
soutenable parfois chez certains élus de
droite donc il ne peut pas y avoir cette
conciliation c'est pour ça que ma
famille politique qui reste la gauche
doit être très clair sur ces questions
là là il ya un fossé il ya une ligne
rouge c'est pas très clair sur ce non
moi je veux saluer les interventions je
suis plus au parti socialiste depuis
trois ans mais je veux saluer les des
interventions 3 de son premier
secrétaire
olivier faur puis sur la question de la
laïcité la lutte contre l'islamisme même
s'il ya toujours évidemment des tensions
des débats il ya toujours ceux qui vont
chercher des explications économiques et
sociales mais elles ont été
particulièrement clair un mot pour finir
ça ça rejoint la fois la gauche et est
ce que vous disiez sur le changement de
la constitution il ya un texte qui est
examiné au sénat il ya quelques jours
une proposition de loi constitutionnelle
qui vise à inscrire dans la constitution
la prééminence des lois de la république
la gauche n'a pas voulu participer au
vote jugeant que dans un tel contexte
c'était trois jours après l'assassinât
de sa mère pattie ça permettait pas une
discussion sereine qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé de ce choix de l'année le
problème c'est de trouver la voie de
l'accord est ce que je vais vous pouvez
vous diviser ce qui était le cas donc
sur un texte de loi
si vous pensez en plus qui va pas
aboutir donc si on considère et je
trouve c'est le cas que cette
proposition est intéressante
vous l'auriez voter vous non je ne suis
pas sénateur je vais pas me mettre à la
place des sénateurs socialistes pas
avoir quand
les inconvénients mais si on veut faire
avancer les choses si on considère que
notre droit ou européen ou national
surtout ne ne permet pas d'aller
suffisamment loin il faut le faire
toujours avec méthode sérénité pas faire
uniquement des proclamations et bien ça
veut dire qu'il faut se mettre autour de
la halle autour de la table si les
sénateurs ou la majorité sénatoriale
veut faire aboutir cette proposition de
loi constitutionnelle elle sait
parfaitement qu'elle devra trouver la
voie de l'accord avec le gouvernement
avec l'assemblée est ici avec la gauche
mais bon cela fait quand même qu'elle
aboutisse mais mon seul appel c'est
qu'il faut se mettre d'accord et les
socialistes qui ont gouverné et qui
m'ont soutenue notamment au sénat
président kader a été membre de mon
gouvernement savent que la culture de
gouvernement la culture de la
responsabilité dans ces moments aussi
délicats face au temps de crise doit
s'imposer
dernière question on a bien compris que
vous ne vous souhaitez pas devenir
sénateur mais est ce que vous pensez à
un retour dans la vie politique
française à revenir de d'espagne
complètement pour vous réinvestir et mon
mon petit destin n'est pas n'est pas le
sujet non je ne suis pas à la recherche
de mandat et de et de responsabilité
mais je pense que d'une certaine manière
l'expérience vous avez avec le dégagisme
on a balayé beaucoup de choses en 2017
responsabilités sont partagées bien sûr
et j'assume mes propres responsabilités
dans dans ces échecs mais l'expérience
elle est utile l'expérience de ceux qui
ont gouverné de ceux qui ont pris du
recul de ceux qui regardent le monde
donc c'est important que les ne vois ma
voix compte dans le débat donc je
continuerai très librement à exprimer si
je considère que c'est utile pour mon
pays si c'est utile pour les français et
on sait conseiller emmanuel macron vous
ai pensé qu il a suffisamment de
conseillers est il là il agit mais je
pense est important notamment par
rapport à ceux qui ne se sont pas
trompés sur ces questions là tout à fait
fondamental de continuer à dire ceux qui
le pensent avec toujours le sens de la
responsabilité et un immense amour pour
pour la france merci beaucoup merci
manuel valls alors était notre invité ce
matin
[Musique]